Yeah, we're going to start off just by M and M in it saying, you know what,
we're coming from a place of ignorance.
This episode is just as much about us enlightening ourselves as it is about
us entertaining you. So go easy on us. This episode is going to be great.
Talking about the wonderful Ru Paul, um, who I love so much. I mean, you know,
if you watch our morning show every day,
a weapon in the morning available@patrion.com slash Bay Ridge boys.
We have a segment called work,
that girl where a Yonis and I sing and dance to her favorite, uh,
to her famous song work. Yeah. And that's only part of it.
The real thing to remember is that segment is all about celebrating women and
those who identify as women and their accomplishments throughout history.
Because let me tell you something, you're coming on. This podcast, low energy,
she got two options right now at two options only. Okay. Bob says,
listen to me either. I'm going to come over there. I'm gonna start caressing.
You're nuts, Zack. Okay.
Or I'm going to give you an Eskimo kiss on your belly button,
even though I know the word Eskimo is derogatory right now.
And I'm sorry about that. So, which is going to be, you want to get your nuts,
your nuts are tickled or your belly button kissed by an Eskimo. I'm going to,
I'm going to go for, I'm gonna go for neither. Is there a third option?
We're going all the way to San Francisco in spirit from one of the most,
I would say, V would you call him? Wow. He goes by him,
Ru Paul.
That's his pronoun as maybe the most influential drag queen of all time.
I would say. Yeah. Father's day during pride month. It's like, right. I mean,
can we get rid of, look if we're going to rip down George Washington,
can we also rip down at some of these patriarchal nuclear family
holidays? Yeah. I mean,
that's so 1987 or even
1777 to even call someone father or celebrate them.
What are we celebrating? Exactly? What are we celebrating a dad?
Yeah. You know what dads did? They created a patriarchy.
You know what that patriarchy did. Okay. It oppressed people.
So let's get rid of it. I want to send my kid to a school that teaches that kid.
How to hate America and hate the father who pays for that school.
Would you joke it to RuPaul is a guy. You mean what? I jerked the RuPaul again?
Yeah. It's already half cousin. I mean, I've been a lot since 84.
Got better snap when you read, Oh, there we go. Yes, that's through it. He said,
you can call me. He, you could call me. She, you could call me Ray,
just a Kathy Lee. I don't care.
Just as long as you call me car.
I liked the that because being gay,
fine. Here's the thing. If you're gay, you're lucky. You're liberated.
You're liberated from these straight limits.
love it. I mean, my hair's moving again. Yeah. Your hair's movie.
That's how you do your Chrissy chaos. Cousin's quarantine. It's
David's mama, the kid Ru Paul. She came to New York city and in the eighties,
in New York city, no, but she said she doesn't matter.
Rumor doesn't matter that she wouldn't get Ruby. Doesn't matter.
In the mid 1980s, Ruby left the South,
headed to New York city and became part of a new festival known as a wig stock.
Um, and then, uh, Ru came to New York, uh,
to New York and became that popular fixture in the nightclub because the
nightclubs in the eighties, must've been fun. Fun, fun. Your brother,
your $3 bill brother was probably bopping around in the 1980s nightclubs.
And you may have bumped into RuPaul. Seriously. He might've.
What I love about the gay community is how very gated it is.
There's so much in the spectrum. It's like when you're a straight guy,
it's kind of boring. We're just kind of shut guys. You know,
some of us read and some of us don't. I mean,
because the gay world is really a Vegas buffet and to the left turn to the
right to let's play it on the run.
Work it girl,
do your thing on the runway.
Sorry to the right shots.
So fierce became such an Anthem that she just skyrocketed to success and
Coke, pop culture, fame. She got a talk show on MTV.
She was interviewing big time. Celebrities. Ru Paul was here. She has arrived.
Yeah. Y'all yes. So she made her feature, film, debut and spike Lee's um,
Crooklyn, um, good movie spike Lee's Crooklyn. Um,
she had her talk show variety show on VH1 in 1996 and what went through 98.
But then she really popped, I mean, really popped for our new pants in 2009,
with the debut of the long running reality TV competition, Ru Paul's drag race,
which I was a fan of. Yeah. Here's the thing about,
I tried to get in Ru Paul Ru RuPaul skyrocket in the nineties, making them sick.
She was on like the cover of magazines and stuff. She skyrocketed nineties.
Then there was this kind of like plateau period.
She put out a couple more albums. They didn't do as great.
Even though one of the songs hit the charts, she was making music. I mean,
she did like three albums. Girl gets saved and get play in America.
You can be anything you want to be.
Somebody just made her a musician and she's a musician in America. There it is.
Yes. Go ahead. Go ahead. Yon.
His quote is we are all born naked and the rest is drag
baby. Very true. As soon as you put clothes on,
you're in drag wearing drag right now,
it may be a different kind of drag than what you're used to,
but we in drag Bobo, it's kind of like the modern form of what Shakespeare said.
The world's a stage and we're all just playing apart because we're not,
we're all just dressing up for each other. Who's what's the true us.
What's the true you the true, true. You you're pretty close to the true.
You I've say I'm pretty close to the true me. I think the true me,
I think the true me is a guy who is very comfortable with themselves.
I think, uh, getting turned on by men, but you know, sexually attracted to him.
I mean, you're turned on by men. You always fly by that.
Thank you guys for watching. Don't forget to subscribe.
Also turn on alerts more to come tell frown. Absolutely.
And go to patrion.com/bay,
rich boys to join the matriarch with Thanksgiving really wide.